he is the head coach of Washington State
football back here on the Rich Eisen
show coach Leach Mike Leach how are you
coach I'm doing good I'm good what do
you think Gardner last night huh
I thought he played good you know it
brings a lot of energy to everything he
does he certainly does I'll tell you
he's caught my eye and obviously last
year helped with all of that
how did how did how did Gardner Minshew
wind up on your radar screen to begin
with coach well we're looking for a
quarterback and we didn't have anybody
that had ever started the game before
and and Gardner had bounced around but
you know you get a Manasa whoever's
transferring or looking for a team type
of thing and he played at East Carolina
and it split time with the guy that had
transferred there from Duke we liked him
better than the Duke guy and but they
both split time the Duke guy he was a
good guy's a big guy would strong-armed
all that and then well so then about the
time we sort out that you know we want
to we want to recruit him he'd committed
to Alabama and so we figured we'd call
him anyway because we knew we threw it
more than Alabama did and so we called
him up and said you know hey you want to
hold the clipboard at Alabama you wanna
lead the nation passing I came to
Washington State yeah now yeah I'm not a
beat around the bush guys so are you
guys kindred spirits would you say
that's an appropriate way to describe
your relationship
now we had a lot in common there's no
question about it really definitely a
lot in common it's you know in the you
got yet thing with him he's if he's a
very tough guy and he's fearless you
know so he was a great guy to coach and
great guy to have on your team did you
hear the story that he hammered his hand
to purposely break it maybe get himself
a red shirt medical redshirt year did
you hear about that story yeah he didn't
quite break his hand but yeah he tried
to that's yeah I told the story is it's
funny because uh you know we had we had
a deal where yeah you know we'll during
camp we'll add some of the guys talked
to the team and talked about their
background or whatever and yeah he told
that story to the whole team well what
do you think of it well I mean by then
I'd known him a little bit and I mean I
know it sounds strange but after you
know Gardner for not too long of a
period of time that really doesn't
surprise you that well you know NFL fans
are kind of getting introduced to him
bit by bit
coach including one moment that my
compadre from NFL Network Mike gar
follow reported that he was spotted in
the way locker room in Houston last
Sunday stretching in just a jockstrap is
that something that he did up in
Washington State - yeah I do that and
the headband on and the aviator glasses
on and like after a game you know
music full blast I don't know if those
dancing or running in place some
combination of false but aviator glasses
headband and and just letting it rip you
know and you know the NFL Network Fox
cameras were trained on on the crowd to
coach Leach and know
getting to meet gardner minshew the
first as well appears the apple doesn't
fall too far from the tree huh oh no his
dad's outstanding and now it's now you
know a lot of these guys you know
professional athletes college athletes
you know I mean the kid gets like bigger
stronger than the father no no Gardner's
dad Gardner's dad could could whip
Gardner there ain't no question about it
Flint meant you could whip Gardner and
him and I mean he actually his dad looks
like he could play too
he definitely does my cleats here on the
Rich Eisen show before I get to your
current quarterback and your program I
mean there you got Cougars all over the
place you got Luke Falk starting for the
Jets in New England against Bill
Belichick what would you say to the Jets
fan base that feels that Faulk is just
gonna be fed to the to the Wolves this
weekend coach well you know things are
tough under the best of circumstances
but you know I think Faulk is a great
game manager I think you'll bring out
the best and other players which is the
ultimate job of a quarterback to make
the you know the feature of the talents
of the players and then you know AEE
knows the offense really well he's a
total student of the game and you know I
look for a pretty good performance at a
fault really what you put them a little
more meat on the bones there what do you
what do you mean by that
well you know well first of all I think
Faulk was uh I think Falk was under
drafted I think um I think Paul you know
the other thing folks the all-time
leading passer in the history of the
pac-12 thinking about that the most
passing conference in the country Fox
the all-time leading passer that
conference and because I think folks
gonna have a career I think he's gonna
do quite well and
and I hope he does I mean because the
Jets have all the money into darn 'old I
mean you think about it this is really
folks kind of audition for the best
possible situation he can be in next
year's you know if you talk about the
reality of the NFL you know and so I
think he's gonna do well these these
games you know he's supposedly a backup
he's better than several guys starting
he's more accurate than a whole bunch of
guys starting most guys starting he's
more accurate than most guys starting I
get a kick out of that you know the NFL
has has all these guys they say well all
he's got to do is work on his accuracy I
mean what do you mean always got to do
his work on his accuracy I mean accuracy
is where it starts
accuracy is like you know working on
your accuracy that's like having a
telephone where nobody could hear you on
the other hand you know you can't
deliver the message mike leach of
washington state here on the Rich Eisen
show HBO is going to do a Hard Knocks
series on four college programs you're
one of them as when is this gonna go
down coach I think they're telling the
week of the Colorado game and they've
been here some alright and you know they
seem like pretty nice guys and obviously
HBO does quality work you know so yeah
should be good
Cillian and plus you know you can kind
of share the the thing with all the fans
and everybody what's your favorite
all-time HBO show do you have one oh I'm
trying to think what all's on HBO
welcome in their own scheme of Thrones
you ever watch Game of Thrones al azhar
that was awesome I watched I watched all
those that was good I guess I got a
little tired of well you know the
Banshees way up north I got a little
tired of that I
the White Walkers and the zombies them
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're coming
there's kind of these these monsters
without any personality that's one thing
that made Game of Thrones was they
really fleshed out all kinds of
characters on there and we did have
personalities and all the rest and the
White Walkers they were just these
monsters at my kitchen they you know you
don't know what a white Walker thinks or
what they do or even what they eat you
know and the other characters I thought
were a lot a lot more well done I agree
with you Michael each here on the Rich
Eisen show I thought what what's what's
with the 9:00 a.m. Pacific start times
being bandied about for the pac-12 Airy
is that really gonna happen next year
for real oh I hope not I kind of doubt
it but I hope it doesn't I mean it's
such a brilliant idea everybody's
against it I mean you talked about
really screwing your fans you know but
now it's a horrible idea
you know if the NCAA has got some kind
of rule where you can't do anything with
the players before 6:00 or whatever and
then now you're gonna get them up at at
4:00 a.m. to have a nine o'clock game I
mean that's crazy I mean and then you
know you've got your fans whether they
tailgate attend the game or watch it on
TV
you know nobody wants to get up and
celebrate the event at that point in
time because we're trying to you know
pandered fans we don't have and that at
the expense of things that we do I mean
that makes no sense to me how would how
would it impact your personal morning
routine though coach I just throw it
right off yeah well I'd probably
wouldn't know better I probably wouldn't
go to bed tonight before to be honest
with you all night are you pulling all
nighter
I might I might I mean but this makes no
sense at all I mean nobody in their
right mind would do that I mean this
isn't 10:00
you know I mean yeah people have
described it as you know breakfast with
the pac-12 like as in breakfast at
Wimbledon okay well this isn't in tennis
I mean football is entirely different
than tennis football you're getting
ready to knock the hell out of one
another for an hour and it takes far
longer to warm up and prepare for and
then the other thing is is the reason
they have breakfast at windmill tennis
because it's in England okay we're not
England it's true I am mandated before I
let you go to have you ranked breakfast
foods coach in terms of all-time ranked
breakfast foods yeah rank the rank
breakfast foods for me if you wouldn't
mind well I would Mike lead you know
breakfast guide but I'll tell you what I
always have okay I'm not a huge
breakfast guy it's probably my least
favorite meal and then when people pull
the stunts of having breakfast for
dinner
it always pisses me off but I have I
always have let's see what do I have I
always have two poached eggs whole-wheat
toast
am us they have it okay in grits
I like grits and like a dress okay but
what about breakfast cereal and you're
not a cereal guy cereal let me think
cereal I haven't had cereal forever I
guess
well nowadays I guess some type of
granola but when I was a kid and they
never lasted that they were fun for just
like maybe one meal because that's not
what they'd last it was hard to beat
Sugar Smacks or fruity pebbles you know
as far as just liking them but I always
felt like I was kind of eaten ice cream
rather than do you know well last one
for you coach my compadre across the
Rich Eisen show studio floor my on-air
compadre Chris Brockman has just found
out he's going to be a dad
do you have any advice for him the baby
is due in February so he has some time
to take all this in and perhaps activate
it in real time well I don't think he
needs to sweat it very much you know
people have been having kids since the
caveman and I don't know why he should
be different than the rest of us you
know he needs to just hang in there and
swing away like everybody else does kids
our kids are actually a blast once you
get past all the you know getting up at
night and then you got a house break
them you know but now I had I had a
pretty good time with all my kids to be
honest with you that's good but I mean I
guess the housebreaking thing is I guess
the advice that he probably needs oh you
got a house break them for sure you know
because now left to their own devices
the kids would go right on the floor so
you got a you got a you got to work
through that a little in it isn't saying
it's kind of funny because I did I had
four kids and I'm the oldest of six some
get it instantly and some it's quite a
process you know to work through that
the logistics of this goes here you know
what I mean coach leach it's always a
pleasure to talk with you really is and
you know good luck against UCLA and
we'll chat down the line hopefully real
soon
well thank you so much it's thanks for
having me on anytime
absolutely you take care of it tell
everybody to buy my book swing your
sword okay you just did what else
it's called swingers Amazon okay swing
your sword leading the charge of in
football in life it was out in 2011
whatever you know what though visit
we're in paperback now is that where we
are yeah no I said both the hardcover
and paperback but it's still selling
pretty well then I got another one on
about its rolling rolling along too I do
the book on tape if you have that that I
would do if you're reading your book I
know I need to do that in
talked about it and we thought about
seven never called the trigger yet okay
well I'm just I'm just trying to make
you better for in the same way you just
made me better so thanks coach
appreciate it you got it that's mike
leach of washington state right here on
the rich transition for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app